[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutte e a
tutti Ho sempre pensato che ogni persona
abbia una dote un'abilità un'attitudine
per qualcosa gli altri però non io
solamente verso i 40 anni però ho capito
che forse in qualcosa sono capace e
riesco a passare inosservata Mi spiego
meglio riesco a mettermi in silenzio per
lasciare posto agli altri è una cosa che
mi riesce e che mi fa stare anche bene e
in poche parole mi so mettere in ascolto
come l'ho capito grazie a un naso rosso
un ulele e una macchina per il caffè qui
rappresentata da una
tazzina partiamo proprio da quest'ultimo
in un viaggio in ritroso nel tempo da
diversi anni Lavoro in un'azienda che fa
macchine per il caffè la Simonelli Group
un'azienda del territorio ma da 4 anni
mi occupo insieme al Team della
sostenibilità di sostenibilità sociale
fare sostenibilità sociale non vuol dire
fare
filantropia per filantropia si intende
un elargizione di denaro a scopo
puramente benefico in realtà fare
sostenibilità sociale a mio avviso vuol
dire mettersi in ascolto del territorio
e delle persone che lo abitano per
cercare di comprenderne i bisogni e
questo è il mio lavoro e per fare questo
ci siamo dati anche dei criteri che sono
appunto l'inclusione le pari opportunità
e il sostegno ai giovani in un contesto
in degli ambiti che sono appunto il
socio assistenziale lo sportivo il
culturale lavoro quindi in un campo in
cui l'ascolto è
fondamentale in cui l'ascolto è
fondamentale
e immaginate Quante siano scivola
immaginate Quante siano le richieste di
sostegno e collaborazione che ci
arrivano tutti i giorni in realtà Dietro
ogni richiesta c'è una persona che viene
a raccontarci la sua storia il mio
lavoro è proprio questo mettermi in
ascolto di questa
persona ovvio che badate bene Il mio non
è un ufficio in cui si possono
appoggiare delle pratiche e che vengono
direttamente accettate ovvio che mi
piace immaginarlo come una stanza in cui
da cui partirà un percorso e forse
avvieremo insieme questo
percorso vi porto un esempio circa 2
anni fa è venuto da noi il presidente
del circolo tennis della nostra città er
era venuto a chiederci una
sponsorizzazione e in realtà ci siamo
messi a chiedere con il mio collega a
fare tante domande perché noi non
conoscevamo questo sport in realtà io
non sono minimamente sportiva e abbiamo
fatto talmente tante domande fino a
quando non è uscito fuori che nelle
Marche non c'era un vero e proprio corso
di whe Chair tennis non c'era un corso
Special in wheelchair tennis in tennis
su sedia a rotelle E allora ci siamo
detti Ma perché non farne uno perché non
portare il wheelchair tennis qui a
Tolentino e permettere a tutti di
usufruire di uno spazio così bello e di
tirar fuori l'abilità di ognuno anche in
questo sport quindi è stato finanziato
l'acquisto di varie carrozzine
professionali stato finanziato appunto
l'acquisto di tutta l'attrezzatura e il
corso con
professionisti capire bene quindi che i
progetti sono molti sono tanti ma il
punto chiave è che si possono
intercettare le effettive esigenze
dell'altro soltanto se si assume una
postura relazionale nei confronti
dell'altro se si nutre un rispetto nei
confronti dell'altro e se si dedica
tempo e attenzione
all'altro quindi l'ascolto deve essere
reciproco non deve essere unidirezionale
ma deve essere un ascolto che va da me a
te quindi in questo modo io mi metto in
ascolto e cerco di comprendere anche le
problematicità che stanno dietro a delle
parole al vissuto e alla visione che ha
questa persona quindi capirete bene che
l'ascolto è molto complesso e pensare
che basti andare a sentire le parole che
l'altro da dire vuol dire non aver
compreso
nulla Non so se conoscete la differenza
tra ascoltare e sentire questi due non
sono due
sinonimi il fatto di si completa
attraverso la funzione
auditiva se faccio così Voi avete
sentito questo rumore in maniera
involontaria ma colui che ascolta In
realtà va più in profondità Cerca di
comprendere cosa questo rumore stesse
dicendo Cerca di comprendere L'emozione
che l'altro vuole trasmettere quindi non
è più un gesto involontario ma
volontariamente cerca di
comprenderti quindi cerca di andare al
di là delle parole dette quindi capirete
bene la mia ansia in questo palco con
tutte queste mani che volano è così che
si ascolta andando al di là delle parole
c'è un ideogramma in Giappone molto
bello composto da tre ideogrammi Che
vuol dire orecchio cuore occhi Tu come a
dire che per ascoltare veramente c'è
bisogno di un orecchio quindi una
funzione uditiva ma non solo c'è bisogno
di un cuore che vada al di là delle
parole dette che cerca di fare
accoglienza che cerca di mettersi nei
panni dell'altro così come gli occhi tu
l'altro da
me capirete bene quindi che in questo
contesto nella nell'azienda è dove ho
allenato la mia capacità di ascolto ma
non è dove ho imparato ad ascoltare per
questo vi porto con me a fare un viaggio
nel tempo andiamo indietro a 7 anni fa 7
anni fa ho iniziato una scuola di
musicoterapia e sono entrata con un
Ukulele in mano un Ukulele
giallo una scuola di Triennale di 3 anni
per cui una scuola importante sono
entrata con una consapevolezza pensavo
di sapere tutto della musica del potere
della musica ma in realtà non avevo
compreso niente Dopo tanti anni di
conservatorio di pianoforte in realtà
non avevo capito che la musica Ha poteri
enormi e che attraverso questa scuola
avrei fatto delle esperienze mai
immaginabili quindi non so chi di voi
conosce la musicoterapia è una relazione
d'aiuto che si basa sostanzialmente
sulla musica o i suoi elementi quindi il
suo
la melodia il ritmo o il corpo e
attraverso la musica si cerca la
finalità della Music terapia è una
riabilitazione un aspetto educativo
terapeutico vi porto con me per un
attimo nel primo luogo in cui ho fatto
il primo tirocinio di musicoterapia con
una musicoterapista è un istituto per
gravi Cerebro lesioni
acquisite è un istituto in cui entrano
persone che sono entrate in coma o
uscite dal coma o che hanno hanno subito
un ictus quindi immaginate uno dei primi
pazienti è stato un uomo che aveva
subito un ictus con una conseguente
fasia fluente una fasia fluente vuol
dire che questa persona aveva dei gravi
deficit comunicativi non riusciva a
comunicare con a chiedere un bicchiere
d'acqua o a comunicare con la moglie
perché quando hai una fasia fluente vuol
dire che nei tuoi pensieri nella tua
testa una frase è corretta ma poi quando
la tiri fuori non parli non riesci a
esprimerti dici parole senza Quindi
potete immaginare la sua enorme
frustrazione a quel punto la
musicoterapista cosa ha
fatto la musicoterapista si è messa in
ascolto ha cominciato a fare prima un
lavoro di riabilitazione fino a che non
ha cominciato a osservarlo a mettersi in
silenzio e a sentire cosa l'altro avesse
da comunicargli e quindi ha iniziato a
un giorno vedendo la sua enorme
frustrazione ha cominciato a mettersi
davanti seduto davanti a lui e a
cantargli una canzone facendogli bene il
suo
labiale la canzone er acqua azurra acqua
chiara acqua
azzurra acqua
chiara con le mani posso
finalment
bere potete immaginare Quindi questa
persona che ha cominciato a osservare la
musicoterapista il paziente ha
cominciato a osservare il suo labiale
poi ha cominciato a dire una sillaba
dopo l'altra una parola dopo l'altra e
poi una frase
intera potete immaginare gli occhi di
questa persona la luce negli occhi di
questa persona quando è riuscito a dire
tutta una
frase e ovviamente il lavoro non si è
concluso in un unico intervento ma l'
intervento è prosegue per tanti incontri
ma finalmente il paziente è riuscito a
dire la parola acqua agli infermieri e a
chiamare la moglie con l'ultima parola
della canzone
Amor la musicoterapia P mi ha aiutato
tantissimo a imparare ad ascoltare ma
non è dove ho imparato veramente a
comprendere le l'importanza dell'ascolto
Questa l'ho compresa grazie a un naso
rosso la maschera più piccola al
mondo Allora cominciamo di nuovo questo
viaggio a ritroso nel tempo e andiamo a
13 anni fa dove ho iniziato una scuola
di clown terapia per diventare clown
dottore 13 anni fa ho iniziato questa
scuola con il baule dei sogni
un'associazione di cui ad oggi sono il
presidente
Anche qui c'è da studiare molto un anno
un anno di corso capirete bene che per
fare queste co terapie bisogna studiare
tanto perché quando si lavora con la
malattia o con la disabilità non si
scherza e si rischia di farsi male e di
fare del male Quindi è bene studiare e
formarsi con la clown terapia vorrei
prima di tutto darvi una un accenno
riguardo alla differenza tra il clown
dottore e clown da circo non so chi di
voi la conosce ma il clown da circo è
quello che si suol dire il pagliaccio è
quello
che fa uno spettacolo entra in scena si
mette il naso rosso e tutto pitturato
sul viso entra e fa uno spettacolo il
suo unico obiettivo è quello di far
ridere le persone il naso rosso del clan
dottore invece no il naso Roso del clan
dottore ha un altro obiettivo il clan
dottore lavora nei contesti di cura e
entra ovviamente in coppia e si trucca
molto leggermente si mette un camice
tutto colorato per cercare di rendere
più umani medici e il clown dotore In
realtà ha una finalità totalmente
differente dal pagliaccio e questo In
pratica Cerca di cambiare di emozioni da
negativa in positiva e non serve far
ridere per fare questo vi porto con me
negli ultimi minuti in in una terapia in
una fare
clownterapia in un reparto di
oncoematologia pediatrica qui vicino a
andiamo insieme entriamo con il mio
collega entriamo in uno sgabuzzino ci
cambiamo velocemente ci mettiamo il
camice e poi andiamo in davanti a uno
specchio davanti questo specchio
iniziamo a truccarci in maniera molto
sottile e a questo punto iniziamo a
mandare lontano da noi tutti i pensieri
tutti i rumori di fondo questi rumori
sono la lista della spesa da fare le
cose da comprare o da il cane da portare
a spasso e e in realtà Qui cominciamo a
fare un ascolto su noi stessi a metterci
in connessione con noi stessi e questo
momento è fondamentale per noi Dopodiché
Usciamo da questa stanza e ci rechiamo
in reparto e cominciamo Prima di tutto
dalla prima stanza e andiamo a bussare
perché Perché è fondamentale bussare
perché il bambino può darci
l'opportunità di entrare o no tutti
possono entrare nella stanza del bambino
anzi tutti devono entrare nella stanza
perché il bambino ha bisogno di essere
curato assistito il clown dottore No il
clown dottore può non entrare e quindi
chiede il permesso e il bambino può dire
di no E questo è già cura per
lui a questo punto Quindi se il bambino
dice di no passiamo all'altra stanza e
se il bambino ci permette di entrare la
prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è metterci
in ascolto Non entrare mai con la voglia
di strafare ma entrare in punta di piedi
e mettersi subito in ascolto vediamo da
lontano una sandina un po' passata una
televisione con una pubblicità che va in
sottofondo una mamma che guarda per
terra e gli occhi di un bambino che ci
guarda un po' incuriosito a quel punto
noi entriamo magari sbattiamo contro la
porta e comincia l'attività la messa in
atto dell'attività del
clown a quel punto iniziano giocolerie
magie cose varie ma la cosa fondamentale
è che non siamo noi a fare magie e tutti
questi giochi è sempre il bambino che ha
il potere di fare tutto ha il potere di
cambiare la sua emozione e alla fine
quando c'è all'apice di questo
cambiamento noi usciamo e lasciamo un
palloncino proprio a ricordare al
bambino che è lui che ha il suo potere
ogni tanto può riguardare questo
palloncino e capire che questo
cambiamento può esserci e tutto grazie a
lui ma cosa hanno in comune la
musicoterapia la clown terapia e la
sostenibilità in realtà hanno dei punti
in comuni belli importanti perché si sia
che io sia una musicoterapista un clan
dottore o lavori nella sostenibilità
sociale mi prendo del tempo e concedo il
mio tempo all'altro per permettere
all'altro di cambiare diverso le sue
emozioni a un anziano magari
di poter trovare le sue parole e a una
persona di poter produrre il suo sogno
quindi concediamoci il tempo per
costruire i nostri
ponti ma sapete la verità in realtà è da
tantissimo tempo che il tema
dell'ascolto è entrato nella mia vita 26
anni fa all'età di 17 anni mi sono
ammalata Ho avuto una malattia pesante
difficile da accettare e con cui
conviver per tutta la vita
e in realtà questa è stata la mia più
grande fortuna sono una persona
estremamente fortunata e Sin
dall'adolescenza sono entrata e uscita
dagli ospedali e in realtà questa per me
sta stata un'enorme Gavetta una palestra
per cercare di comprendere e capire
veramente Cosa significa ascoltare ho
iniziato a ascoltare in ospedale in
realtà mi sono messa in silenzio e
ascoltavo la mia vicina di letto che
aveva necessità di parlare delle sue
paure delle sue insicurezze dei suoi
dolori Così come mi mettevo in silenzio
ad ascoltare i medici quando avevano
qualcosa da dirmi o quando non trovavano
le parole per dirmi qualcosa quindi io
ascoltavo i loro sguardi i loro
silenzi in realtà questa malattia mi ha
portato a fare la prima connessione che
è stata con me stessa perché essendo una
malattia subdola devi cercare di
comprendere anche solo il minimo
cambiamento che il tuo corpo ha per
cercare di anticipare un dolore un
ricovero un intervento in realtà di
connessioni poi ne sono scaturite
tantissime tante e tante sono le persone
che ho incontrato da cui ho di cui ho
fatto tesoro in realtà e tante sono
diventate famiglia
e in realtà questa malattia ti toglie
tanto e ti toglie il tempo ti
toglie ti dà dolori ti toglie forze ti
toglie tutto ma in realtà al netto di
tutti questi dolori di questi interventi
fatti delle montagne scalate in realtà è
più quello che ho ricevuto che è quello
che ho perso in realtà questa malattia è
strana perché mi haato una disabilità
invisibile E questa malattia è in realtà
passa inosservata proprio come me
e credo però che passi inosservata solo
per chi non si mette veramente in
ascolto questa è la mia capacità di
ascoltare in poco più di 15 minuti vi ho
raccontato la mia capacità di ascoltare
e spero che possa essere d'aiuto anche a
voi per imparare ad ascoltarvi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie